>> Tucker: WITH WELL A CARAVAN
FROM CENTRAL MEXICO IS GOING
THROUGH MEXICO AND DEMANDING TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE DISLIKE IT
AND SO HE IS CALLED A WHITE
SUPREMIST.
>> IT IS AN ARMY AND INVAGSZ OF
BROWN PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA.
THIS IS THE IMPLICATION.
TUCK THIS IS AFTER THE HAPPY
EASTER TWEET PRESIDENT TRUMP
WENT AFTER IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: THE FIRST GUY WHO WAS
A POLITICAL APPOINTEE FOR OBAMA.
>> AND THE LEFT IS MAKING
A POINT THAT WE HAVE NO RIGHT TO
DENY PEOPLE ENTRY WHEN THEY COME
HERE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO OR WHERE
THEY ARE COMING FROM IS THATMENT
POSITION?
>> YES, AND WHAT IS WHACKY TO ME
ABOUT THE TUCKER, HALF OF THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT POPULATION
INCLUDING THE 1100 PEOPLE OR
WHATEVER IT WILL BE BY THE TIME
THEY HIT THE RIO GRANDE AND HALF
OF THE ILLEGALS IN THIS COUNTRY
CAME HERE SINCE 9/11.
AND IN OTHER WARS, THEY BROKE
INTO A COUNTRY THAT IS ON ORANGE
ALET.
WE ARE TOMMED WE ARE ON A ORANGE
ALERT.
IF LAW- ABIDING AMERICANS GO TO
THE AIRPORT.
BE ADVISED SECURITY CODING FOR
TODAY IS SUCH AND SUCH.
AND YET 1100 PEOPLE ARE
ANNOUNCING THEY ARE WALKING THE
COUNTRY AND THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT THROES UP ITS HANDS
AND SAID WE CAN'T STOP THEM.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF ORANGE
ALERT AND 300 MILLION AMERICANS
SHUFFLING THROUGH THE AIRPORTS
BIKE A BOVINE HERD IF ANY OF THE
SIX AND HALF BILLION PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT AMERICAN CAN COME OVER
THE RIO GRANDE AND TAKE A FLAT
BOTTOMED BOAT AND COME.
>> Tucker: THE POINT IS WE ARE
THE PROBLEM.
JIM OR WHATEVER HIS NAME ON CNN
TOLD US THAT WE ARE THE PROBLEM.
THEY ARE VIRTIOUS ONE AND SHUT
UP AMERICA AND OBEY.
>> HE PROBABLY DOESN'T KNOW
THAT.
THERE WAS A FRENCH NOVEL
PUBLISHED AND I A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT DON'T LIKE IT.
IT PREDICTED WHAT IS HAPPENING.
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE GOT IN A SHIP
IN INDIA AND SAILED TO THE SOUTH
OF FRANCE AND ALL OF THE MEDIA
COMMENTED WHAT IS THE BIG DEAL
ABOUT THIS.
WE ARE THE SINFUL ONE AND WE ARE
THE STAIN OF ALL OF THE WICKED
ISM, AND IMPERIALISM AND THEY
ARE THE VIRTIOUS ONE AND LET
THEM IN.
>> Tucker: YOU GET THE INPREGZ
THAT YOU ARE SOFTENED UP AND
PEOPLE TELL YOU TO SHUT UP AND
OBEY.
AND WE GET TO THE MOMENT WHERE
WE CAN JUST BE TOLD TO STEP
ASIDE AND LET PEOPLE COME IN
YOUR PLACE.
>> AND I THINK THAT IS LARGELY
WHAT IT IS IN FACT.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHY I PAY
GREAT TAEJZ TO THE LEFT'S
ASSAULT ON LANGUAGE.
SOMEONE IT SAID YOU KNOW.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS IS ANTIIMGRANT.
I AM AN IMMIGRANT.
IT IS BORING BULLPEN YOU GO FILL
IN PAFRP WORK.
AND THE LEFT APPROPRIATED THAT
TERM AND NOW IT IS AN ARMY OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T BOTHER WITH
PAPER WORK AND SIMPLY FROM BEING
IN POOR IMPOFERRISHED COUNTRIES
AND WHOSE RESOURCES THE UNITED
STATES PILLAGED SUPPOSEDLY.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO WALK IN
TO THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
SO WHY SHOULD WE CARE THAT
A STATUE TO PRESIDENT WILLIAM
MCKINLEY.
A VICTIM OF GUN VIOLENCE IS
ABOUT TO BE TORN DOWN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT FEELS LIKE IT IS WORTH PAYING
ATTENTION TO.
WHY IS IT?
>> IT IS WORTH PAYING ATTENTION
TO, IT SHOWS WHEN YOU HAND THE
LEFT A VICTORY THEY MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT THING.
RICH LOWERY SAID ON FOX NEWS
LAST YEAR, HE SAID HE DIDN'T
FEEL TERRIBLY EXCITED ABOUT
DEFENDING ROBERT ELEE OR
JEFFERSON DAVIS.
BUT IF THEY COME AFTER
WASHINGTON AND LINCOLN HE WILL
BE THERE DEFENDING THOSE GUYS.
TEARING DOWN STATUES OF AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS AND A GUY WHO TOOK
A BULLET FOR HIS COUNTRY.
ONCE YOU GIVE THEM AND HAND THEM
THE FIRST VICTORY.
THEY SIMPLY MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ONE AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS
INTERESTING TO ME, TUCKER,
OBAMA, WHEN HE LOOKED FOR IN
JUDGES.
QUALITY OF EMPATHY.
THAT REQUIRES US TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HUMAN BEINGS IN THE
AGE IN WHICH THEY LIVE.
YOU ARE NOT TEARING DOWN
A STATUE OF MCKINLEY.
YOU ARE TEARING DOWN THE
REPRESENTATION OF ALL AMERICANS
WHO VOTED FOR HIM AND AGREED AND
SUPPORTED HIM.
YOU ARE DISOWNING YOUR OWN
HISTORY AND SAYING I AM JUST
GOING TO LIVE IN A HYPER PRESENT
TENSE DISCONNECTED FROM MY PAST.
>> Tucker: I KNEW YOU COULD